all right freddie peralta down the hill
for milwaukee and
he had a great start in his last one did
what he needed to do against a
struggling arizona
team uh tim six strong innings of one
hit
shutout baseball it comes a 3-1 to
peterson
for john peterson his first walk since
june 2nd peterson at first nobody out
drives that one into the air high to
right field
that one back near the wall and god
a towering home run for ian hat i mean a
roof scraper
it gets out of here and just like that
the cubs
on top two to nothing for ian hat number
nine
two balls no strikes on the ground only
man over there
is urias winds it up and a bad throw
and safe at first luisa's hat is
throwing problems
all year long and he starts then stops
and peralta strikes out sogar during the
inning
a lead off walked in a two-run homer by
ian happ
and kyle hendricks will hit the mound
with a lead in the first inning
he's been really good his last eight
starts he's eight no
and a 225 earned run average last two
stars 12
innings no runs he's five and one on the
road should i continue
he's got a stretcher 15 consecutive
scoreless innings
slowest fastball velocities in the
majors
and leans out on one that is down a base
hit
and peterson over to cut it off that's
going to hold
us to a single nice play by peterson and
the brewers come out with a base hit to
start the game offensively
right off the end of the bat that is
going to work for extra bases
cerius on his way to third yelich with a
q
shot double he's 5-0 with a 2.37 here in
the month of june
swaying at a miss struck him out
and the brewers have them loaded in this
first inning and here is avi garcia
and garcia lines one to center field
here comes yellow it's bottled in center
avayas will hold his ground
this game is tied quickly as amazeo
garcia
delivers a two-run single for a guy who
is not
six feet tall he throws it like a guy
six
eight there's a swing and a miss put it
right by alcantara
a couple of k's for peralta got him on a
four-seamer
a strike call got him with a fastball
peralta with back-to-back k's this
inning
big moment early for peralta base is
loaded
and he got him punched him out with the
faces loaded
here's the pitch curveball got him
looking frozen
and hendricks bounces back and looks
razor sharp in the second
we move to the third to two
0-2 pitch swinging out of this he got
him
trying to get that slider close enough
with two strikes to make it look like a
strike
[Music]
the one-two in the air left-center
yelling closes on it and the inning is
over
peralta needed that one one two three
his fifth strikeout
bottom of the third coming away from
american family field we're tied at two
so trying to counter their aggressive
approach
throw a little lively stuff inside now
he comes back with a change up and boy
you didn't have to alter your scoreboard
after all
two away for ravi garcia garcia down the
left field line that's well struck
it is gone avi garcia
have yourself a game he's driven in all
three runs brewers up 3-2
here's jose lobatone 2-2 pitch and a
swing of the miss
put it right by him second time he has
struck out
low baton 3-2 brewers lead fourth inning
down he goes got him with a fastball
seven
k's for freddie peralta six of those
coming on the gas
2-2 pitch got him fastball
fooled him 96. tremendous success with
two strikes against big league hitters
a little soft liner for an out in the
first of them
there goes maez throwing a second the
tag he is out
this will be peralta's last inning as
he's typically been
even when he's dominating a six-inning
pitcher there's a bun
so guard it's a good one peralta picks
it throws it what a play
freddie peralta okay bouncing off that
mound like a cat
answers with some great d to bring up
kesten hero
that's a base hit slow roller into right
here comes peterson
hiro drives in a run 4-2
milwaukee in the sixth patrick wisdom is
going to get a chance right here
with a man at first and wisdom
represents the tying run
crushed left fatal and we are
tied look out wow
holy cow heads up in wauwatosa
yikes two and nothing to count with
adamus at first
chaff and ready and deals
diving play chris brown gets up steps on
the base
he made two spectacular plays in the
inning
one and two the count williams deals he
struck him out looks like it's a pretty
good pitch right from the get-go this
area
williams ready
and so now two aboard
righty deals inside and he walked him
the 3-2 swinging a ground ball to first
shira has it
and he gets out of it go ahead and run
at second base
and it'll be jackie bradley jr
in the end he will deep left center
field on the run
half can't get it off the wall it goes
peterson will score he'll hold hira
belly flop back to the bag he's safe
jackie bradley jr delivers
taylor in the air left field coming in
here's peterson he's got it here is
going to try it throw to the plate
off the mark heroes in sac five at rbi
adamus tonight is one for forbes and the
pitch
swinging a drive in the left center and
deep way back
[Applause]
and they have opened up this baby
wow what a shot
[Applause]
peterson down the right field line
another hit
here comes levis he'll score
garcia will be held around third it is
11-4 it's a seven-run eighth inning for
milwaukee
two balls two strikes second and third
seven runs are in it's 11-4 milwaukee
here sends it deep to right there she
goes
a three-run home run a 10-run inning
this will be a fun match up here you
know buyers is gonna let fly
and right off the end of the bat shallow
here comes taylor he's got it
how about six pitches six strikes three
up three down ninth for sanchez
and the brewers put the cubs away in the
opener of this three-game series